خطر منطقته الغام الاف الهكتارتي شمال
مقاطعه دونيتسك التي كانت تحت سيطره
القوات الروسيه اصبحت اراضيه محرمه بسبب
انتشار الالغام الارضيه فيها
وفي اثناء مرافقتنا لاحدى فرق نزع الالغام
سقط صاروخ قرب احد المنازل ولم ينفجر
تغيرت الوجهه فتلك احدى مها من الفريق
[موسيقى]
كثيرا مع اثرنا على اجزاء خطيره حيث يسقط
الصاروخ غير المنفجر لكن يبدو ان الوضع
هنا امن
عاد الفريق لاكمال عمله الاساسي وهو تنظيف
ومحيطي احد خطوط الكهرباء الرئيسيه
المقطوعه لحمايه ارواح من سيقومون باصلاحه
واعاده الخدمات الاساسيه
عثر هنا على جسم مشبوه يصعب التعامل معه
اختار الفريق اسلم الطرق للتخلص منه
وقديفه لم تنفجر في عموم مقاطعه الدنيا
على ثلاثه اضعاف في هذا العدد ويبدو ان كل
سنه من الحرب ستكلفنا خمس عشره سنه من
العمل لازاله خطر الالغام
الارضيه تشكل واحده من اخطر المشكلات التي
تواجه المناطق التي استعاد الاوكرانيون
السيطره عليها
ستمتد الى ما بعد الحرب فضلا عن عوامله
دون عوده كثير من السكان الى هذه المناطق
في الحرب لم تنتهي بعد وما زالت قرن تتعرض
للقصف كمان معظمها يعاني نقصا كبيرا في
الكهرباء والماء والغاز والتدفئه
ترفض فيكتوريا الرحيل عن بلدتها فقط تطوعت
لاطعام عشرات الحيوانات في البيوت التي
هاجرها اهلها
من الحيوانات دون اصحابها هي بريئه لا دخل
لها بما يفعله البشر
بسلام بقينا نحو سبعه اشهر تحت الاحتلال
والان نحن احرار لكن الاوضاع لا تزال صعبه
في مناطق اخرى لم يعد هناك قرا اصلا لكي
يعود اليها سكانها فكثير منها اصبح اثرا
بعد عين الجزيره شمال مقاطعه دونيتس